[Music]
you think you know how the world works
you think that this material universe is
all there is but what if I told you the
reality you know is one of many this
doesn't make any sense not everything
has to felt estranged
throwing the mystic Artes we harness
energy and shape reality the Avengers
protect the world from physical dangers
we safeguarded against or mystical
threats come with me
who died protecting this world mr.
doctor
mr. doctor it's strange maybe Who am I
to judge
dr. strange you think you know how the
world works what if I told you the
reality you know is one of many
this doesn't make any sense
not everything does not everything has
to
[Music]
for the mystic arts we harness energy
and shape reality
we travel great distances in an instant
you
I get from here to there how did you
become a doctor studying practice your
sins
there's a strength to him but is he
ready
careful which paths you travel down
strange stronger men than you have left
away
I have death
and pay
you'll die detect all this world
I can't give it there is no other way
I've spent so many years
here in through time
looking for you
but what's this my mantra it's the Wi-Fi
password we're not savages
you
Stephen strange might I offer you some
advice
forget everything that you think you
know
your man looking at the world through a
keyhole
you've spent your life trying to widen
it
your work saved the lives of thousands
what if I told you
is one of many
believe in fairytales about chakras or
energy or the power of belief
I see in your future
possibility
are you doing this
so much you don't know
[Music]
you